[Music]
on the outside
the five of you are villains
predators
remorseless sociopaths
oh stop you making me blush
we're the bad guys
and this is the crew mr snake serpentine
safe cracking machine imagine houdini
but with no arms jackpot yes
miss tarantula our in-house tech wizard
where'd you learn to do that mostly
youtube mr piranha he's brave crazy
what's up papa
and mr shark master of disguise his
greatest trick stealing the mona lisa
disguised as the mona lisa
and rounding out the crew is me the big
bad wolf we may be bad but we're so good
at it all right we're out of here so
long suckers
well this just got a little weird
if only we were given a chance to be
anything more than criminals if you want
to stay out of jail you need to go good
what are you doing we're gonna pretend
to go good the bad guys become the good
guys so we can stay in the band guys
it's fantastic wolf you're a genius
welcome to the first day of the rest of
your best life look it's a cat stuck in
a tree what does your heart tell you to
do a good person would
smack it in it stab it saute it
i want you to save it
we're more than just scary villains they
love us you're such a good boy
maybe i don't want to be a what a bad
guy no no no
we'll always be bad guys
let's try something simpler i'm going to
give you a push-pull just for me no to
share this is going to taste extra
squeaky
nope
sucker
i'll teach you the [ __ ]
totally worth it
[Music]
bye